welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is ian miller an agrarian Studies
program fellow at the macmillan center
and an assistant professor of history at
st. john's university as an agrarian
studies fellow he is exploring conflicts
over wood resources and the development
of private institutions for production
forestry and woodland conservation in
early modern China today we'll talk with
professor Miller about the development
of forestry in early modern China
welcome professor Marilyn how are you
good thank you so let's begin with the
book you're working on tell us about it
sure so like you said in the intro I'm
working on a book on forestry and early
modern China and I'm really interested
in sort of the interplay between three
different questions so the first
question is a sort of large-scale
institutional question about where the
wood on sort of long distance lumber
markets is coming from how the state is
managing its wood supply and and
basically how the the large-scale flows
of both sort of fuel wood and timber are
working in early modern China the second
question is a much smaller scale
institutional question and it's really a
question about wood rights and about
property rights okay and so here what
I'm interested in is around the world
historically wood is a common resource
so it's like everyone in the village has
the right to go and cut firewood from
the common woodlot complied in the early
modern period it changes and wood starts
to become claimed as a private property
and one of the reasons for that is
because now you can sell it on these
long range would markets or also because
the state is making stronger claims to
wood and so I'm interested in how that
takes shape in China because actually
the question of property rights is sort
of interesting and somewhat fraud
question in Chinese history as well
and then the third thing that I want to
do is to combine this large scale and
the smaller scale institutional
perspective to try to say something
about the long-term environmental change
long-term landscape change in China and
this is another sort of fraud question
in Chinese history because we're
addressing a narrative that holds the
China experience sort of long-term
deforestation and really quite severe
deforestation and so I'm trying to use
both this large scale and this smaller
scale perspective to add some nuance to
that story okay when you say early
modern China help me with the years sure
about sure so I'm talking principally
about the period between about twelve
hundred and eighteen hundred although I
range a little bit earlier than that and
a little bit later than that as my
sources techne and as you're looking at
China are you also looking at other
parts of the world in terms of what
they're doing the West for instance
Japan perhaps yes and are they similar
or very dissimilar and their approaches
sure so the core of the book is a study
of China but I'm very much motivated by
the comparative historical perspective
and so if we look at Europe for example
this is a period when I mean especially
after about 14 15 hundred European
states first Venice and then later
places like Spain and France and England
and the Netherlands and then later the
German states become very much concerned
with where their supply of timber is
coming from and so they're innovating
new forms of state oversight and in
particular territorial oversight of wood
production um in particular to ensure
that they have enough wood for their
navies because this is after all the
period of colonization in the period of
pretty intense naval competition between
these Atlantic powers they're using a
lot of wood to build ships exactly and
you know and it and becomes a strategic
concern because if the Netherlands has a
better supply of good ship building
timber that means they're going to have
better naval ships and they can you know
can test the Spanish right in that realm
and in Japan um we see you know a
somewhat different trajectory
nonetheless the same overall trend which
is that you know this concern of wood
shortage brings the Japanese state and
in particular so the Japanese state is
divided into individual sort of
territorial Lords in addition to the
more centralized state and they all
become involved in controlling wood
production again out of concern for wood
shortage and so my interest here is that
um we should be seeing the same thing in
China right especially with this
narrative of deforestation and
environmental decline well that also
means would shortage and in the rest of
the early modern world the threat of
wood shortage brings these states with
their growing bureaucracies and they're
growing military infrastructures into
concerns with directly controlling their
supplies of wood and so this is really
sort of the question that brought me
down this research path is the
comparative question okay and so how is
china different from the rest of these
places yes so it's different than them
in the sense but there's just much less
state forestry okay and um and the thing
that okay so when you say less state
forestry meaning the government is not
controlling the forest that it's more
privatized or it's no one is controlling
it and it's a free-for-all so that that
sort of later statement is I think the
way people may be used to think about
China but actually one of the things I'm
trying to show is that even as the state
is not directly involved in managing
forests on the ground there are other
parties that are doing this okay so
talked about that yeah sure so this is
um really what the second half of my
book project is about which is how
private families and these are you know
we shouldn't think like the nuclear
family these are large you know sort of
family structures get involved in
controlling woodland so very prominent
families typically what is a so these
would be the most prominent families in
their locality but if
a little bit different than in Europe
where you have this titled nobility
China doesn't really have a title
mobility after about the ninth or tenth
century in the same way there's a very
thin one at the top but um but these are
you know the most important Gentry
families in each village in each county
by and large and they own large
properties and then they innovate all
kinds of different financial instruments
to deal with their investment in
especially in timber and to a slightly
lesser degree in fuel wood and the
reason for this is actually quite
interesting because so if you think
about the early modern economy it's
mostly agrarian and so when you're
talking about grain crops or fiber crops
or even you know tea it's something you
harvest every year right and so it's
very easy if I own a plot of land and
then I sell you the plot of land for you
to take over the management and do what
you want sure if you want to plant mill
it instead of tea it's easy for you to
do that but when we're talking about
timber this takes 20 30 plus years to
mature and so if we want to figure out
how to transfer the management of the
forest from me to you or to subdivide
the management so that you know I get a
half-share and you get a half share or
also to distribute risk so that instead
of each of us owning a half share in one
for us and maybe it burns down so that
maybe we will get together with 20 other
people and each own you know a smaller
fractional share in 10 different flights
and so you know you see the early
development of risk management
structures and things like something
sort of akin to a futures market and
developing in the wood economy how about
were they planting new trees new
saplings to replace the ones that were
cut down was that a part of the forestry
and what they were doing back then so
absolutely and this is this is one of
the real important turning points in the
development of forestry worldwide is
going from sort of natural replacement
where you cut selectively in the forest
and then you let the acorns fall or
whatever and grow
their own trees you know of their own
accord to a move where we're now clear
cutting and then there's no seed trees
there so we have to go and plant
seedlings and saplings and so both of
these are things that um the techniques
for planting seedlings and saplings are
described as early as i think the 5th
century feather 6th century but for
timber trees they become important in
the 12th century before that it's mostly
for fruit and things like that and by
the time you get to the 15th or 16th
century this is the dominant form of
forestry in some parts of China where
they're absolutely cutting a whole block
of trees and then planting them again
some seedlings so I'm curious to know
how you got interested in this
particular topic yeah so I guess I'm a
little bit of an environmentalist which
a lot of people of my generation are but
I'm also interested in and concerned
with social justice and so I was very
interested in this sort of interplay
between these two different concerns and
especially when you're talking about a
common resource like the way that woods
were in the early modern period and and
so on the one hand you have the threat
of environmental degradation and so that
leads people to create new institutions
to prevent it right to enforce rules to
to make sure that what that is cut is
replaced what have you but the thing
that's very interesting to me is that
the people who get left out when you
start enforcing new regulations on
common property are you know exactly he
would expect it to be it's the poor it's
women especially widows it's outsiders
and immigrants and so I was very
interested in how this plays out this
this sort of conflict between wanting to
extend rights to these you know sort of
people in less stable circumstances so
that they can contain
you you know reaching a level of
subsistence but at the same time wanting
to prevent environmental degradation so
in doing their research is there any
specifics you can offer in terms of the
balance between ensuring there's enough
wood and that not all that not too much
has been cut down yeah sure so in terms
of a lot of it plays that plays out in
terms of these large families that I was
talking about before and in particular
the question of what to do with excess
population hi this is the problem that
we see all around the world right but
it's the question of if you are in a
limited setting likes a village right
and its surrounding lands that there's
only so much farmland and for us to go
around right and so if you have more
people than you need to grow more food
and that's going to lead you to cut down
the woods but then if you cut down too
much of the woods you don't have enough
fuel to heat the you know to cook the
food or to heat your house in the winter
and so your left when you have too many
mouths to feed with this question of are
we going to starve or are we going to
freeze yes and so what we see is these
families finding ways to encourage
emigration what are they um well so
there are a few um so one is that the
poorer branches of the family will
increasingly be cut off from the recent
from a common resources shared by the
family and so pretty brutal it is pretty
brutal and so these are these are
conceived as institutions that go
towards supporting all of the
descendants but in fact what we find is
over the course of generations you
inevitably have you know one brother
who's rich and another brother who's
poor to make a very simple example right
and so then the the descendants of the
rich brother will increasingly control
the entire family property or have more
control of the family property than the
descendants of the poor brother and so
over time you start to see them denying
access to common woodlots denying them
the right to bury their dead in a shared
graveyard and
also things like if they don't pay their
dues because these are actually dudes
collecting organizations in addition to
everything else if they don't pay their
dues they don't get access to the shared
school they don't get to participate in
family rituals and all of this stuff and
so it's a way of not so subtly saying
hey I'm telling time to leave maybe
you'd be better off going west and
seeking your fortune in the new frontier
maybe you'd be better off on a merchant
ship trying to make your your living
that way work you know or just as a
peddler right traveling to countries
yeah that's very interesting in terms of
doing your actual research I'm curious
to know about your methodology alone
also did you come across specific
stories in terms of people talking about
this like oh you know my flat my family
is basically you know telling me I have
to go then I'm a bird and then I have to
speak my first we are kind of thing
interesting so so the challenge of this
research has been that it so in the
beginning it was very difficult to find
sources would even talked about wood and
so it was a process of figuring out what
are the other ways that they're talking
about this okay and so do we often see
people saying you don't get firewood
anymore actually not that much what we
see instead or what I've seen instead is
that graves play a hugely important role
in in these family and what lack and so
the in at least two ways one is that
they're the ritual center of ancestor
worship and so if you don't give people
the right to bury their fathers or their
grandfathers on the collective plot what
you're saying is you're not part of the
family anymore you don't get to be part
of these rituals anymore and you know if
you can find another place to bury them
good for you but um but then the other
thing is that graves are actually there
in the woods and they are used to
control access to the woods a lot of the
time so not all woods have graves in
them but most graves at least until
about six
700 have woods around them and so access
to the grave sites is not just about
ritual it's also about access to
firewood do they still have the grave
graveyards in woods today so this is
still a strong tradition but it's become
um maybe superficial is too strong a
word so part of it and this is one of
the questions that I don't know that I'm
totally able to answer is win these
woods get cut down I tend to think it's
largely in the nineteenth and twentieth
century when China goes through a whole
series of crises but as late as 1800
Western travelers are still describing
this is what Chinese graves look like
especially in the South there they've
got woods behind them but then you know
in the modern period some of this
preference to bury near trees becomes
sort of formal formulaic and has
actually very little to do with the wood
so you'll see people putting like
plastic trees next to their graves or
you'll even see people making online
memorials to their ancestors and there
will be like tree gifts or whatever next
to it so the tradition persists but it's
changed a bit and part of that is that
in the modern world access the firewood
doesn't matter the same way it did prior
to say the late 19th century all right
China is a huge country so I am curious
you know if you are you looking at all
of China or a particular part of China
and if you know and if it's all over our
things similar just similar in some ways
yeah so I've done fieldwork principally
in two provinces who again and Jung see
which are in the south fujian is on the
coast you see is is the next sort of
most interior province and really the
story that I can tell mostly focuses on
the south and on in particular on wood
exporting regions of the south north
china is very different so the North
China Plain is has very little wood okay
from probably quite early in history and
then when we're talking about Manchuria
the Northeast that historically was home
to non Semitic people's to Manchus and
Mongols and so with the last imperial
dynasty in china this was actually a
Manchu controlled dynasty and so they
had very different forms of Land
Management for the Manchu lands in the
Northeast then for the Chinese lands in
the rest of the country so yeah my study
primarily focuses on the south okay all
right so you talk about warring states
philosophers and when you discuss forest
regulation so what effect did these
philosophers have on later policies sure
so this is one of the most interesting
things about looking at policy in China
so the warring States is a period from
sort of the fourth or fifth century to
the 3rd century BC so this is almost two
millennia before the period that's the
main focus of my research but my the
poly the policy makers in the 15th 16th
17th century are still using the
arguments of the warring States of the
third fourth fifth century BC to make
their arguments and you is there a
reason why that is do you think I mean
do you have a kind of timeless as to why
that would be so I think that there are
two reasons so the first is that
political philosophy in China basically
starts in the warring States and a lot
of that is because this is the period
when States the period the early period
of State Building in China and so with
the emergence of recognizable forms of
polity you also have the recognizable
emergence of forms of political
discourse and so up until the 19th even
early 20th century these ideas still
have some currency because the
institution's themselves actually have a
great deal of continuity going back to
millennia the other reason which is very
actually closely intertwined to the rise
of states is this is the earliest period
where there's a clear experience of
environmental degradation of
deforestation in particular and so not
only are these early philosophers
reacting to the rise of states but
they're also reacting to the possibility
of environmental degradation and so the
early States um these warring States and
then the earliest empires in China are
able to draw on this body of philosophy
to argue for certain forms of
conservation right okay and so you know
it's not just the earliest policy
arguments in general that go back to the
warring States but it's specifically the
earliest environmental policy arguments
that go back to the warring States okay
and so those are the these same ideas
that are getting I mean I guess in some
ways it's the Silent Spring moment right
it's the the moment when they realize
the possibility of totally degrading
their landscape right and so the
political will and the ideas about how
to use this political will to create
sustainability are created right right
you know so huh and listening to you say
that happening you know so many
thousands of years ago it makes me think
about today in terms of you know some of
the things we're facing in our world
today in terms of deforestation and
environmental issues so I guess I want
to ask you does the early history of
Forestry in China teaches anything for
today yeah um I think it does I mean we
have to be careful applying the lessons
of history that there's a phrase I turn
a phrase I really like which is history
doesn't repeat itself but it rhymes
right and so some of these same issues
that we see at least in general terms in
as early as you know the 3rd or 4th
century BC are the same issues again in
general terms that we see today and so
the the interplay between questions of
preventing environmental degradation and
questions of ensuring equitable access
to resources are things that people were
dealing with for
hundreds and really thousands of years
in China and that we're dealing with now
and so when we talk about deforestation
in the contemporary world the places
that were most concerned about
deforestation its not New England it's
not Germany right it's it's not really
even China anymore it's largely places
like Indonesia Brazil right and these
are by and large poor countries and the
regions that are being deforested are by
and large poor regions and so when we're
talking about halting this deforestation
and encouraging sustainability in the
Brazilian rain forest we also have to
think about what effect this has on the
locals who rely on forest resources for
their subsistence right it is a
complicated situation you know in
addition to the people of the animals
that are displaced as well so it is it
is a very complicated situation and so I
think one of the things that that doing
this study has has taught me is that
sustainability is absolutely an
important goal right but we also have to
be aware of what people are doing in the
name of sustainability we need to be
aware of when governments are using
sustainability as an excuse to claim
resources for themselves or even when
corporations are using sustainability as
a resource as an excuse to claim
resources for themselves saying you know
these these peasants don't know what
they're doing they are burning the
forest down let us take care of it we
know how to manage the resources
efficiently and so this is something
that I mean I see myself continuing to
be concerned with even as I move past
this specific project is this question
of the interplay between sustainability
and equity in access to resources right
so more to come I hope so yes thank you
so much for being here with us today
Thank You Marilyn it's been a lot of fun
thank you for more information about
professor Miller and his research please
visit our website at macmillan report
yale edu be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
Macmillan report made possible through
funding from the Whitney and Denny
Macmillan Center for International and
area studies at Yale
[Music]
you